wait a minute did she hallucinate this
dude before she shot because that opens
up a can of worms if she thought she was
shooting turkeys this shot is awful if
she thought she was shooting at this
dude
she's awful hero in the sequel has PTSD
about the events in the previous film
cliche how do the companies that create
these video displays stay in business
this picture is awful it looks way less
convenient than technology we currently
have today hey I want a video playing
device that has a transparent image so I
can also look behind it while I watch it
convoluted plot development has the
president of the entire society forcing
Katniss to pretend to be in love just to
serve this weak-ass love triangle that
was weak-ass already in the first movie
oh yeah apparently everything in this
society is videotaped probably mentioned
in the book somewhere but it sure
surprised me answer me this assholes why
the nude cameras right outside her door
if they can just pull up high-definition
video of her randomly kissing in an
alley any old time they want all you
need to do is give a few speeches wave
to the crowd all right 14 minutes in and
they're about to do what we came to see
speeches and waving
I said enjoy it Kenneth you've earned it
by killing people if I recall you barely
killed anyone in the last movie you
nearly got through the whole thing
without having to do it once and one of
the bad guys conveniently killed your
new friend roof or you and PETA didn't
kill anyone that I recall he was too
busy camouflaging himself to look like a
tree to kill anyone if the information
in that room is that sensitive why have
the door cracked open in the first place
I asshole I'm really not in the mood for
lecture I'll apologize to Fe later here
hey MIT you might have been expecting a
lecture but would it have hurt you to
make the tiniest of glances in that
direction to make sure it was him before
you started ranting see Katniss the way
the whole friend thing works is you have
to tell each other the deep stuff see I
said the exact same sentence to a girl
once but I swapped the word give instead
of tell it was not well received clean
what's yours later on when this movie is
over and you realize it's being two and
a half hours long the scene about the
favorite colors begins to feel less and
less important rule it's a year older
than she did when she died
putting away script to say something
heartfelt cliche these people still have
no idea how to properly flip someone off
shouldn't President Snow be able to
watch and listen to this conversation
with his omniscient cameras he's ready
to evaluate in the districts you think
so they don't believe our love story no
kindness you should've told me that
before went out there and tried to give
these people the money
dude you went off-script remember also
what does any of this have to do with
making the people believe you guys are
madly in love the guy not killed because
he did the Mockingjay thing while
Katniss gave her Ruchi what is out there
who protects them
Haymitch suddenly cares about non
Haymitch people yes what were you
thinking it sounded like she was paying
tribute to room didn't fu say it was
customary to give eulogies even if
Katniss and Peeta had made out on stage
wouldn't the eulogy part still have
potentially led to that guy getting shot
even if they were reading off cards I am
think abused he looks pretty good for a
guy who was shot in the head come to
think of it the steps look immaculate
Peeta
you stay with me ah geez she's not
actually gonna fall in love with him now
is she I barely understand this thing
when snow is watching it at the Everdeen
house but his own house is this the best
a rich man can do with TV technology in
the future even though Katniss and Peeta
have been taken off stage the broadcast
is still showing all the angry people
instead of being in love you two sound
like you're reciting from a drilling
manual you guys are still going with the
we've got to show them how much in love
we are angle after all you've seen does
that really matter get married all these
people are writing because they live
lives and they don't like that they're
young people are thrown into a battle
royale every year you think a marriage
is gonna make them forget that this
isn't some creepy Capitol guy touching
Katniss this is some creepy extra
touching Jennifer Lawrence Katniss and
Peeta heard that then certainly some
Capitol people heard that no this
marriage is a sham
what's this if for when you're full it
makes you sick you can go on eating how
else could you taste everything Wow a
society that's racist classist and
bulimic Philip Seymour Hoffman is in a
movie that has beneath him in the scene
ha ha gross again with the cracked open
security door are you kidding me did a
12 year old write this movie what the
fuck but maybe if we got away from here
we went somewhere safe it could be
different or maybe President Snow is
recording this conversation and you're
giving away your entire plans you
forgetful stupid person every last
soldier doesn't see Gale running toward
their commander right now I'm trying to
figure out whether this is brave or
stupid
I mean maybe Gale thinks he'll be a
martyr or something but it really
doesn't seem to have much of a plan
before tackling the sky I better run
that sounds exactly like my secret
boyfriend getting beaten in the square
you recognize her Katniss Everdeen King
seriously no man they would have been if
Gale had gotten himself whipped in the
summertime the broadcast cut out here
after Gale tackled this dude they
immediately went here for the flogging
and they got a camera at a slightly
elevated angle to broadcast it but where
is the camera
it would have to be in this building
somewhere they have cameras everywhere
including this scene where they caught
the stolen kiss then how can Katniss
somehow sneak out into the woods into
restricted areas whenever she wants
let's face it these cameras are wherever
the movie needs them to be for the
convenience of the plot
are to be reaped from the existing pool
of victories in each 50 I take it from
the reaction that this is the wrinkled
Plutarch was talking about and it was
unexpected but what were the rules of
the other quarter quells the movie sure
as hell isn't telling you that
forty-seven minutes in and we're still
just setting it up here Peeta has to
survive we have to do whatever it takes
to see what
since when is Peeta neo why is he the
one that obviously needs saving which
they call his name of volunteer in his
place but that isn't how this Quarter
Quell should work at all how can you
have an all-star edition of The Hunger
Games but still leave the volunteering
intact I know they just want Katniss in
the games they know no one can volunteer
for her but such a small pool of
contestants leaving that room in his
dumb sad what a dick the last time we
saw people do this three finger flip off
salute a dude got shot in the head for
it and people died but this time okay we
got these games so we're fine with
letting people rebel now but this year
you'll be facing other victors and they
all know one another why is that we saw
Katniss and Peeta went back to live in
district 12 after they won except for
the victory tour which was a whopping 12
days so when did the victors from the
previous games have time to spend with
other previous year's victors to get to
know one another
do they have conventions like annually
and Katniss and Peeta just haven't been
victors long enough for this year's
convention to occur I want you guys to
forget everything you think you know
cliche you go it alone their first move
is gonna be to hunt you down I don't
know what Haymitch expects here
Katniss can't even make the relationship
between she and Peeta believable how's
she gonna win friends with all the other
killers who were already friends with
each other did they all continue a
rigorous workout regimen after they one
did not a single previous victor ever
half of the moral quandary about winning
that Katniss and Peeta have did more
than 5 seconds of thought go into the
plot of this movie the more flames
masters of camouflage does every
district have a male and female winner
from different years to even go to this
because I'm calling bull quit on that
wouldn't there be districts that don't
even have any victors but I would love
to borrow that outfit someday Katniss
doesn't borrow that outfit right now
with the arrival of Toby Jones we now
have way too many people who play Truman
Capote in this movie that is a Donna
tympani oh I see they spent a good
portion of the bigger sequel budget on
the fire
Exce still not enough though from
district 11 this is what any of us would
want to do upon meeting Jennifer
Lawrence but actually doing it that's a
sin man not cool
cameraman forgets to pan down isn't
Peter gonna brush up on his cake
decorating what's the point of the
individual evaluations these people not
all already cleared for the game simply
by being chosen are they going to
disqualify you if the talent portion of
your program isn't satisfying to them
I mean someone painted a picture on the
floor here is their skill that old-ass
lady did something god knows what may be
hugging but is there really anything on
the line here do they have another
female former victor that can take
Katniss's place if she somehow flunks
this evaluation all the other tributes
use words to try and win over the
sponsors but Katniss is only weapon is
fashion I have a feeling snow isn't
gonna go his way so even the psychopaths
in this group don't want these games to
happen why does the fashion designer go
with the tribute when they're about to
get thrown into the games who does Peter
have escorting him it's not Effie the
more allies she betrays the more friends
she kills the more she reveals her true
self why is President Snow even buying
this Katniss is not a real killer and
the last games proved that it takes 83
minutes for the actual Hunger Games to
begin in the second Hunger Games movie
you could start this movie go and watch
the entirety of South Park bigger Longer
& uncut 81 minutes including credits and
still get bat before the actual games
start and I suggest you actually do it
that way done random psycho killer
apparently had no plan when he ran
towards these two but man where his
footsteps ever silent how did Peter win
did he choke that dude to death
underneath the water after that dude
pulled him down that was quick for a guy
who's never killed anyone before
unnecessary tension over whether Peter
might die when we all know that if he
dies it won't be because he hacked a
forcefield with a sword and ready here
we go with those cannon ready orders
again doesn't the cannon person know
their job are they too busy doing Sudoku
puzzles you in Stannis ask a guy whose
heart stopped if he wants to stand up
for seconds after it started beating
again
stupid Pan Am game maker programs
colorful lizard into the game arena just
so the director can have this fun little
establishing shot here are all those
people we didn't have time to give it
about what is it
I think it's a Spile I guess Haymitch
can't write on the note what the gift is
she's got to guess
Chiti
Finnick we have to go I'm amazed they
got this far away from the fog to be
able to care for Peeta and then have
this dramatic moment but the fog was
right on top of them just before Phoenix
started screaming sorry you should be
dead
get a cannon ready magical hill comes up
out of nowhere to help them fall to
safety now the fog is disappearing
altogether we learn later it's because
each threat is contained to its own
quadrant but that's really fucking
stupid I can have tributes running
through an invisible force field that
somehow contains fog magical water comes
out of nowhere to help wash off the
poison Katniss makes it sound like Peter
should just be able to quickly backtrack
a route they took while running it in
panic from a killer fog sci-fi heroes
surrounded by angry monkeys cliche well
our common ancestor isn't a monkey but I
have a feeling that the villains and
movies copied there one at the time
attack patterns clever application of
the monkeys hate salt water science fact
which everyone knows how can she
possibly still have that many arrows
left it's like the same amount she had
in the first place
you have fresh water we can get just how
Peter left the Spile in the tree way
back when the monkeys attacked these
freaking idiots immediately start
ignoring the genius who helped them
figure out the clock thing even though
she's still clearly rambling important
things
oh come on you know for a fact that's
not prim I mean seriously
come on they might have been better off
just leaving the fire effect Rafi in
getting the extra CGI budget to these
jabber J's if you die and I live I'd
have nothing nobody else that I care
about what was all that bullshit you
were screaming earlier about having a
family to protect well I have family too
okay people I need to protect
because gravity plan was always to get
you out and put you in the most
difficult arena in the history of The
Hunger Games to accomplish that plant
also what was the plan before Katniss
shot the dome with her electric arrow
sure they cut out her tracker but
everything is televised you know nothing
is secret how are they gonna accomplish
all of this without Katniss doing what
she did Gayle tells Katniss he got them
out in time so she has to figure out
what the hell he meant by that okay so
there's no more district 12
lots of stuff hanging in the air and you
won't be able to see what happens until
next year when we deliver you the Hunger
Games Mockingjay um part 1 oh and by the
way over 10 damn minutes of credits
get to the beach
ah see Katniss the way the whole friend
thing works is you have to tell each
other the deep stuff a deep stuff yeah
like what like what is your favorite
color
I'm not quite dead sir I think I could
pull through sir
last year was child's play right the fog
is poison
Charlotte breathe is people real it's
the PAL the Black Pearl
thank you